[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are doing something
totally new for us
experimental we're going down the rabbit
hole mm-hmm and what I mean by that is
we asked you guys a question on Facebook
and Twitter and we said it's not a hole
on a rabbit it's a it's a rabbit that a
hole goes into right well it's not that
either yeah it's a conversation that
starts from something and turns into
whatever it might turn into with no
agenda and then turns into something
else and then turns into the rabbit hole
now we're gonna go down that rabbit hole
and let me so we ask you the question
what are you thinking right now and then
Cody and Jacob actually collected well
they caught one in this envelope so they
collected one answer and we don't know
what it is and it's in this envelope and
so we're just gonna read what one of you
was thinking and that's gonna be the
thing that starts us down the rabbit
hole that's what the meat of this here
biscuit is going to be just an
experimental format just to try
something yeah I'll talk more about what
I think about it and why I'm excited
about it
but we're not going to start when we
when we're on the edge of the hole yeah
wait till on the precipice of the hole
we got one foot in the hole I can see
the hole from here but I'm we got to
walk up to it and the way I want to walk
up to it is just just to give you an
update and also to give you an update
today is one of those rare days right
where we don't see each other until
right now
yeah we need more of those we should so
you can't take that as if I want to not
be with you yeah yeah I miss you a lot
today Rhett I'm very curious what
happened on the right thought about you
we divided we did a divide-and-conquer
day of work yeah so I went to the beach
man can't you see him hiding I could no
I did work No
okay good I'll tell you what that is
kind of what I'm asked is like prove
that you were working as hard as me oh
I'll show you without me there yeah so
we we got some catching up to do we
can't go a day without catching up on
that do you want me to tell you what I
did
well in general we we split up for me to
go to a buddy system post and for you I
presume to to lay in more of the details
associated with our live show later
while laying out the two of the
mythicality
yeah right no I wasn't laying out of the
beach I was here at the office I was
we've got a pretty good idea of what
we're gonna do on the tour of
mythicality
hmmm I'm just filling out some of those
details and writing some different
suggestions that we can explore together
and land on this Pacific created but I'm
excited about it it's a good show I saw
your guitar by your desk
it's hardly near the GMM desk not your
not your office desk so does that mean
you were working up there and that we
discussed I may or may not have come up
with a really great way to extend a song
that is an old song that's very fitting
for that night that we're gonna sing
first song we're gonna sing unless
things change okay yeah
and it's updated nice most of the
updates on you though I made the update
but yeah I gave you the responsibility
for the update right now you'll
understand what this means later hmm
okay you don't want to go ahead and tell
me well I was let's see today I watched
the final episode of season two of buddy
system for the first time so that means
I've seen the whole thing now as of
today you have not no cleansing one
through seven yeah so episode eight I
watched and boy I I'm just like did you
cry I was in I was in a critical giving
feedback mode you know how it is the
first time you see it you just it
doesn't wash over you like you're an
audience member because you're already
thinking too critically about okay this
is not what I expected this is what we
can tweak this is how we can make this
better or re-edit it too
to make it deliver in the way that we
want it so so I will say yes there was
there was a lot of emotion involved a
lot of that comedic emotion which is
always good yeah that it was funny but
there oh yeah I think it's I think it's
gonna work is not quite there yet but
I'm I'm really excited but I mean the
first thing and I say this after the
first time I watch every single episode
is what have we done this is this is so
nuts I mean we said we've we said this
throughout the whole process but it was
weird because now that I've seen it all
it's okay I do feel like it's it's
getting close to being over but it
actually ain't because then a lot of
stuff then I had to go back to Episode
one because that's in the final stages
of putting it all together and sitting
in like this theater and finalizing the
sound mix this is this is tedious work
you would hate it then now that's why I
don't do it that's why you're not there
and I'm there because you know I I
relish the details right so I have to
keep perspective and make sure that I'm
giving notes on the right things and not
taking too long
I mean it's so tedious man we listen to
the whole mix and the whole point is to
get every little sound at the right
level and emphasize the right things and
make sure you don't lose comedy and we
listen to the whole thing and then we we
start giving notes when we realize that
the background track was muted the whole
time and we didn't fully realize it like
what do you mean they add like room room
tone room tone ambience like if you're
outside you add like oh we're in a park
so there's like Park noise and stuff
like that and it adds a level of
scrutiny to everything else that's a
little unfair
so everything right without room tone
that seems like the way to do it and
then to add the room tone in after that
except then it then you got to watch it
all again and so and watching again is
not just 22 to 30 minutes it could be an
hour of watching the game because I
don't know
there are frustrating moments but it's a
lot of work I mean
once you get in there but we shouldn't
both be doing it of course not and I do
enjoy it don't I know I what I enjoy is
what is what I did today in terms of
buddy system mm-hmm is I enjoy looking
at the cut putting down timecode and
making all my notes and sending in an
email to know knowing that you were
gonna be the one that had if I'm like we
really need another take of this I don't
want to be the one watched watching the
five takes of that I want you should be
the one watching the five - yeah I got I
got I know when we need a new take but I
don't want to be the one finding it and
I got your email and I immediately
counted I was like one two three four
when I counted all the notes you had
quite a few notes on this episode my
heart kind of sunk and then but I feel
like if I was sent to you that email you
to like hit trash I mean like oh I got
this well none of this really matters in
a certain point you want to talk
yourself into that it's like what I put
I did episode 6 which I think the reason
I gave so many notes is because I mean I
like all the episodes on it's I just
feel sorry for you guys who don't have
you to read I know some of you are in
places that you just can't get it you
can't even buy the shows individually
and then some of you are just in a
situation where you're just not gonna
pay for it I wish it was something that
every mythical beast could see season
one and especially season two just
because I think it'll be more and more
accessible so I think that problem is
gonna diminish see but episode 6 is
excited about it's the most different
yeah and so I just kind of like was like
I just need to give every thought I'm
having because some of the times I'm
like I have a thought about this but
it's not it doesn't really matter and
somebody else is gonna catch this or
it's not worth talking about is and so I
but I was like I'm gonna I'm gonna dig
into this one so I probably gave you
about five more notes than normal is
fine I like the notes I mean they all
can't be be addressed perfectly do you
address all of them not yes no not not
to the best of my ability yeah I did I
of course I have a lot of notes myself
so it all comes together so I'm very
excited
about that you know I feel like I'll
shot out of a cannon into this into this
space but I think the thing that really
set my day off right if I'm gonna go
back and give you a full update is first
thing I did was I went to the dentist
mmm that's not a good day
I was it was just a routine cleaning it
was been six months since my last
cleaning they wanted me to come in six
months later and well that's typical oh
it is yeah that I mean something I used
to go like every year every six months
is the preferred schedule for cleanup
for cleaning well that explains why it
hurts so much
six months ago when it had been a couple
of years right this time was like so
easy and I was getting praise from
everybody like your teeth are good oh
really
even the wisdom teeth I don't think we
have to pull them yeah now if you want
to address the crowding I can give you
like a orthodontic ol consult that
dentist
he's a compliment or though I'll go to
the same dentist he gave me so much
praise about my teeth and I was like
dude you know I mean I know I haven't
been I haven't been here for a couple
years
deflate my prey I'm just telling I don't
you just said everybody was singing
praises of your teeth I'm just saying
that when you've been to that dentist
one time and I noted I made a mental
note he's really telling me lots of
things about my teeth that I know can't
be true because no one's ever said them
before everything he said about my teeth
I believe could be true
so oh you're doing a real good job Wow
kind of hurting my did you say things
like that you're doing a great job I'm
looking really good thank you right I no
longer feel like I've been shot out of a
cannon I feel like I crawled out of a
just a pipe which I thought was a cannon
but it turns out it was just a drainage
pipe well the funny thing is is I
already knew that she went to the
dentist because when I got in my car
today and I plugged my phone in and my
what do you call it Apple car
what if foot is the Apple play apple
play car play well Carly I don't have it
so I plug my phone into my car and then
the apple carplay interface comes up
along with any places that I need to be
and apparently the first place I was
supposed to be was links dentist because
we were I put it on your calendar I want
I was hoping I was looking for you so I
said what hat well so when I woke up and
got in my car I was like twelve minutes
from your dentist appointment
traffic was light I could have made it
in time but I but I didn't I didn't
follow the computers I actually I
navigated to work well hold on did you
just say that when you woke up you were
12 minutes away from my no I'm saying
when I got in my car okay so the first
time I like really registered he than
anything on my phone was when I got into
the car that was when I found out what
time your dentist appointment was where
it was there's a weird how long I had to
get it's on my personal calendar but
there's some weird alert [ __ ] shared
calendar alert thing that's happening I
don't know how I have your calendar on
my calendar I don't add anything to my
counter because I don't use I don't I
don't properly use calendar functions
that's like on Monday I was like oh yeah
I went and got a massage yesterday oh I
get your massage upon no all the time
like that's weird you know not supposed
to know what because I get one of your
massage updates I'm like I should
schedule a massage but that would
require scheduling you could just show
up five minutes before me and say you're
me you could have got your teeth clean
this morning if you were five minutes
early that's true if you weren't if you
were out of bed I know everywhere you're
gonna be when you're gonna be there just
show up a little earlier and just get in
the chair the thing I felt besides
really boosted what are they giggle I
generally a cleaning well they didn't
give me they didn't give you any drugs I
sat in the car and I thought to myself
this is the cleanest my teeth will ever
be in my life mm-hmm the way it feels
when you put the tongue on my teeth the
back of the well never be as clean as
they are right now and so and I just I
just sat in that moment for a second and
my teeth will never be as clean as they
are right now and what and good so I'm
gonna do something with him I'm gonna
get him dirty I'm gonna eat a biscuit
well don't worry what do you how do you
apply that you just want you just being
in the moment I was just trying to be
Zen thing yeah like a Zen thing like
perspective like you know what my moment
right now is the cleanest my teeth will
ever be and I'm gonna acknowledge that I
don't think that ever a compliment on it
and a teeth hygiene though I don't think
the Buddha ever said anything about that
because you know what right now can you
say that right now
no a teeth have been cleaner definitely
yeah and you know my a cleaner my teeth
have been cleaner this morning I mean
couple of meals yeah it was recent I can
remember it but it's not right now
I would say not this moment but your
teeth were cleaner at one point like
when they were first formed my teeth
will never be as clean as they are right
now again as they are yeah that's true
I still drin if no it's no longer true
the moment is passed yeah yeah it was a
moment and you know it was a moment that
I savored alone it sounds like it was a
great time I'm glad you had it yourself
and I'm just I'm trying to do that
because my though my water dispenser on
the front of my fridge is fixed because
that used to be my moment when I would
push you know I talked about it on here
I'd push the water
I pushed the cup and then the water
wouldn't come out and there'd be a delay
and that was my moment to take stock of
life okay and how long is that moment
again just few seconds but now it now it
seems not enough
now it's instantaneous and I'm not even
grateful about it that's my point
mmm now that the water works perfectly I
got to find something else I could say
that you might want to share that moment
with somebody though because I feel like
if you left the dentist office
especially then a dentist that has
complimented you so much even though
it's just he does it with everybody
if you then if you realize that when
you're in the car just say you know what
go back into the dentist office it's
like bus back open the door I'm say guys
body my teeth will never be as clean as
they are right what is it what is the
saying I think that's it yeah
but but they will be them there'll be
clean again my teeth have never been as
clean no that's not what did I say
my teeth are is clean right now as they
will be a couple of weeks I said my
teeth are as clean right now as they
ever will be that's not what is see it's
gone I can't even say it right Yeah
right did win the motor club next six
months from now cuz I already made my
other appointment you'll get an alert
I'm gonna bust in after I exit and I'm
gonna say guys and I'll say whatever I
figured I will listen back to the
beginning of this podcast so I know what
to say the problem is if you go in and
you say that to the dinner
he's gonna make it his slogan so then
you go back to it and he'll have it
printed on the window Derby
your teeth will never be as clean as
they're about to be and then he's gonna
put that on the back of the phone book
that's a long bumper sticker but I go it
your teeth will never be as clean and
they're about to be again mmm that's
what throws it off but you too long one
more I think the reason why we like it
is because it's a paradox your teeth
will never be as clean as they're about
to be well no they're about to be that
clean yeah so they whit yes they will be
that clean and then when you come in
right no no no this is it your teeth
will never be as clean as they're about
to be and then on yeah that clean on the
inside of the dentist office on the exit
door from the office yes that's where it
says your teeth will never be as clean
as they are right now that's what I said
until you come back please make an
appointment unless you come back unless
you come back in six months yeah I think
we should have just been dentists I
wonder if this is all wrong though if I
go gonna be wrong if I can't if I go to
the dentist again if I show up there
tomorrow morning
and I say and they're like mr. Neil we
cleaned your teeth yesterday why are you
back in the ER they were great today
we're the cleanest they've ever they
were as clean as they will ever be and
we're like well maybe not so I'm like
I'm back clean him again they'd be
cleaner well they were cleaner
yeah today then they were yes I think
they would be they definitely would be
shoo this whole thing has been a shame
exactly the moment that's what I was
trying to say a couple of minutes ago
but I couldn't couldn't quite right my
wrap my mind around it yeah again you've
ruined this is a second moment for me
sorry miss dribbling tell me about your
dentist applause I'm dribbling out of
the drainage pipe of life thanks to you
I'm gonna give you a second to recover
while I let the people know about the
products that we have before us on this
table we've got the ear biscuits jar and
we've got the boiled for safety mug yes
we are both drinking out of two
different containers no I'm actually
actually drinking out of the
for safety you can drink something to
stain your teeth mm-hmm any beverage
that you want in there right totally up
to you we don't sell bet off see we just
sell the containers for the beverages at
mythical dot store this has got a good
listen to that it's it's what do you
call that enamel metal I call it a
tinging sound ten I would call that ten
but it's not hmm it's nice whatever it
is support internet payment mythical dot
store and this thing is like a hardened
batter of biscuit okay are you ready to
go down the rabbit hole here's the
envelope I'm gonna turn it over so we
can see the part that we would rip open
I notice you use a piece of scotch tape
you didn't use you didn't lick it you
didn't use your own spit like I
appreciate that
guys there's a risk associated with this
I'm a little nervous but to me this
represents I mean just what we like
which is something new that you go out
on a creative limb and you might you
might fall and rack your nads the tree
limb itself may break and then you may
rack your nads on something else I
thought you're gonna say this is
something do we like talking and that's
gonna be the principle of developing a
device which then makes us be creative
in a new waste like what's gonna happen
is this gonna fail I'm a little
concerned about that
oh I'm not concerned dude we talked
about your dentist appointment for 20
minutes and came up with two slogans for
dentist that would both be great I'm not
nervous at all he's opening the the
envelope listeners and he's pulling it
out all right you're gonna read it and
then we're just gonna we're gonna go
I shouldn't build it up so much we asked
you what are you thinking about right
now Frank Neves said I'm thinking about
the first guy who ever shaved and how
many times did he shave before the
second guy caved now here now you guys
picked this what you what you probably
did
No and this is it and this is what makes
it great was this is a lyric these are
our words we wrote this this is from the
rhett and Link archive guys this is from
a song called I am a thoughtful guy
mm-hm
your line in the song because I don't
remember wrapping it I'm thinking about
the first guy who ever shaved and how
many times did he shave before the
second guy caved I pretty sure that was
your life
really we both yank that it was the
other guys line yeah which that's we
happen to works we haven't watched this
in so long now you guys didn't know that
you just thought you thought that Frank
C Neves came up with like a really good
thing that he was thinking right then
well and that's what I felt you know
what all he thinks is rhett and Link the
lyrics from back in the day see you you
got it you guys don't know the archives
well there's too much to know you so
much to know we don't want you to know
it because we don't even know who sang
the lyric
[Music]
think about the first guy who ever
shaved and how many times before the
second think about if a friend we're
choking on ice
just be patient would be the best advice
here's what I'll say though let's go
with this let's go yeah let's go with it
because we wrote it as a thoughtful
thing to think but by doing a sample or
breaks they actually didn't think about
it that's the ironic thing about that
song is that we actually don't think
about any of the things that we wrote in
the I am a thoughtful guy song we just
thought there's a mop funny no Rob yeah
and it would be that I would like to
think about this but I'm not gonna
really think about it because the
exercise at hand was to write a song
about it wasn't it's actually think
about which means that the whole song is
a lie the whole song is full of lies
because we're saying I think about this
I'm a thoughtful guy when in reality is
I'm just a songwriter not even thinking
about these things it's actually think
about it it's yeah I think we should
before we do it is interesting that I
remember I'm not trying to take credit
for coming up with the concept for this
song sounds like you might be but I
that's a byproduct of what I'm saying in
that I distinctly remember where I was
when I thought about running a song
about deep thoughts or I don't know if
if I pitched it as I'm a thoughtful guy
but maybe I did but I remember I was at
the I was at the fat burger in Sherman
Oaks owned by Queen Latifah she owns
that one I like to think that she's she
I know that she owns one or some but I
don't know that she owns that I heard
that she owns half of all the ones in LA
so what 50/50 chances she owns and want
to Sherman oh I've never seen her there
I've only been there once well I might
have been there more than once but I was
there alone you weren't there and I was
sitting there even a fat burger alone
was it yeah it was the president I was
in the car I was in the car eating alone
and I was thinking about songs and I but
I don't I don't remember much after that
except how good
that burger was don't get the turkey
burger there though I'm almost positive
I did not write this line weather and
I'm pretty positive that you performed
it but I'm also pretty positive that you
wrote it so do you remember writing this
line my memory is not that because I
remember how he wrote this song we both
independently wrote a whole bunch of
thoughts that you could think and then
we kind of pitch them to each other and
then we organize them when we put it to
the song then we wrote some together and
figured out oh there needs to be some
shorter ones at the beginning and by the
end of the song is gonna be so like some
more involved once I remember all that
so I'm putting this on you because I'm I
believe firmly that you wrote you came
up with this line so I think that you
were think you thought it up
Wow Wow
just put yourself back in that place
even though you don't remember writing
it well I think maybe an easier exercise
is just to think about to actually think
about the first guy who ever shaved
because are you thinking about that guy
this is not the type of this but this is
a type of thing that you would of you're
saying that you didn't you just thought
of it in the context of the song so you
didn't actually you have no further
thoughts besides what we're gonna come
up with right now um that's okay yeah I
mean shave rhymes with cave you know you
just come up with some rhyming pairs and
then oh the first guy who ever shaved oh
and then what second got caved you know
just I can't explain the process man I
know that like you talking like
Neanderthals or is it neanderthal well I
think are hairy in the face most of the
most scientists say Neanderthals even
though there's a name we used to always
say in the end or Thals there is an H
yeah but you can see the silent sea man
they're all dead but they have been
talking about bringing them back but the
end there but they're relics of their
DNA are within all of us to varying
degrees that is a controversial the
scientific community is currently split
on that there are some people 23andme is
you know 23andme takes the side that
basically you know in its
the book I've talked about this book
multiple times the sapiens I cannot
remember the author's name but sapiens
New York Times bestseller that basically
tells the entire history of humanity and
he talks about the all the different
people that existed alongside all the
basically humans humanoids and humans
not Homo sapiens not specifically our
species but the other humans that were
sort of branches off of Homo sapiens you
know basically cousins and that you know
we weren't so far separated from them
that we have a lot we had lost the
ability to enter breed so there's some
people and I think he made it sound like
it was like 50/50 right now but one side
of the of the coin is we separated and
you know millions of years passed and
sort of the populations were isolated in
the nice they came back together and we
took him out
but of course meaning that Neanderthals
the Homo sapiens took took out the
Neanderthals but we also you know
interbred a little bit enough to get
like 1 to 3% of their DNA into our DNA
and so it varies from person to person I
think I was pretty high I think I had
like a lot of caveman in me although the
cranial capacity of Neanderthal was
either the same or a little bit more so
the the whole idea that they were
stupider is just something that's like
in popular culture but there's no reason
to believe that they had less
intelligence than we did but then the
other camp thinks that then that didn't
happen we didn't we didn't we just we
wiped him out and we didn't really know
breed with him interbreed but did we
shave too but do they all when we
talking about nano time just talking
about I'm talking about
pre homo sapiens or Homo sapiens before
you say I mean you cavemen we don't
think that like homo erectus shaved the
first person to actually I mean that's a
good question
did-did-did it we can't answer but yeah
first of all we're assuming that they
had hairy faces
I mean I've seen all the renderings I
guess that's the safe assumption well we
still have hairy faces so they
definitely had hairy faces we with
anything we've been we've been getting
less hairy yeah yeah I go back six
million years to our common ancestor
with chimpanzees of course at that point
we're probably got a lot of hair and
then slowly you lose body hair lots for
lots of different reasons but you retain
it in a couple of places and one of the
places is on your faces and then some
guy decides it's interesting that before
that one guy decided to shave it that
from an evolutionary perspective that
the places where the hair stuck around I
tend to think more about the eyebrows
like why is there hair still up here you
know and I think it's prehistoric
sunglasses it absorbs light it allows
you to see and dig to see easier when
it's sunny well it's like while baseball
players put black under their eyes
that's part of it but it's also the so
you've got one guy who's got eyebrows
and you got another guy who this is a
vast oversimplification of natural
selection when it comes to a trait like
this but you got one guy trying to catch
baseballs and another guy trying to
catch bass but the funny thing is is
that so there are multiple processes and
I'm not an expert that led to you know
some of it was climate and that kind of
thing but leading to us shedding the
majority of our hair and not needing all
the hair but then the problem is if you
go too far you lose the eyebrow and all
of a sudden you got sweating your eyes
and your and like you said you also got
Sun in your eyes and so the guy who got
sweat in his eyes and Sun a Sun in his
eyes it is less likely to survive and
reproduce than the guy who doesn't get
Sun in his eyes but they don't you mean
maybe they made it more in the Sun maybe
the ladies thought that the eyebrows or
the men thought that the lady's eyebrows
were more attractive that what you're
saying because that also is a driver of
yep of change it could be but I'm just
saying more simply like you got it
I guess you don't have to see in order
to mate so I'll throw that out but it
helps it does help it helps quite a bit
I would say certain parts of it and
those times back before I mean you know
in in today's in modern society you can
have lots of different disabilities and
it doesn't affect your ability to
reproduce because this is a modern
society and we people are supported in
all kinds of ways but you go back to
more animalistic times and I mean there
are still cultures that they've observed
you some of these isolated tribes and
this is also in sapiens like isolated
tribes that are still around and we can
talk to the people who descended from
these folks their parents and
grandparents there are cultures where
when somebody gets weak like when
somebody gets too old somebody comes up
behind you and kills you with a rock ooh
yes so there's a culture I don't know
where it is Amazon rainforest or
something but there was a dude and he
was the designated killer Rock dropper
and so like typically when an older
woman got too slow and was holding
everybody back he went up behind her and
killed her with a rock and it was just
an exciting
grandma hit everything everybody was
related and it was just this understood
thing and the culture like if so if
that's an indication of what it was like
you know hundreds of thousands of years
ago for all humans you didn't want to be
somebody you didn't want to be the blind
person because you might have get a rock
on the head and obviously for very good
reason and thankfully that kind of stuff
doesn't happen anymore but that's pretty
horrible
so the yeah so I would think that would
have been a disadvantage to not have
eyebrows and when mating but why did
somebody decide to shave because first
of all anybody who is exede from an
evolutionary despite perspective decided
to shave your body doesn't make any
decision you know what I'm saying though
everlue the evolutionary process
blindly decided where to shave a lot of
our bodies okay so like all this all
this hair oh my butt well on my body
like some people have more chest here
than others like back here back hair is
is more of an anomaly from an
evolutionary perspective but but we
evolved the ability to still keep hair
right here around or just around this
part under the nose in front of the ears
and down below the jaw line connecting
if we're a real manly man like me or
something neck ting down below the
goozle to the chest hair which is the
superior and upper happy trail as I like
to call it but what is your point that
evolution stopped there and then man had
to make the decision well before why did
they make the decision well first of all
you know you don't know if evolution
happens a is so slow that you don't know
that the the evolution of facial hair
isn't continuing we just can't perceive
it which is why aliens don't have beards
you ever seen an alien with a beard
that's a good point right but we have
the distinct advantage a very very small
very small minority of people who have
ever existed on earth have the ability
to know that there was something
different before us so because you could
come to the conclusion that like this
dude somewhere a couple hundred thousand
years ago was like I see the pattern
here
I see how it seems like we're
progressing towards less hair so I'm
gonna go ahead and do the do the work
that evolution is going to do in shape
no they obviously he didn't do that
because he didn't perceive that we
perceived we may perceive really hairy
people as more caveman like like when
you see a really hairy dude at the pool
right like a dude we're just like crazy
back here and he sholde her hair that
you could you could just you could land
in and you might look at that guy and
say that guy seems more like a caveman
and what I imagine a caveman to be
we're talking about my dad he so gentle
your dad seems more like a caveman than
my pets that's what we're saying and so
but this so then you would come to the
conclusion that that's a negative thing
but that's only coming from a modern
scientific perspective everybody else
who before we had this understanding of
our of our past would see a hairy dude
and wouldn't think anything about well
he's more caitli to know what a caveman
was it didn't understand human progress
they didn't even understand time in a
way that we understand time but this
dude who decided to shave had to think
that the hair was somehow less dignified
and maybe it wasn't comparing himself to
previous humans but it was comparing
himself to animals right hmm so you look
at yourself and of course humans the
natural instinct of every human is to
think that your satchel you're special
and you're separate from animals that's
why there's so many people who still
don't believe in evolution because they
choose to believe that how we can't be
related to all these animals because
we're special we're different
right and so that's that's doesn't
totally natural instinct of humans to
think and so side note I I think it is
possible to believe that you're special
indeed I believe that we are we are
where people are special in terms of
conscience a soul whatever you whatever
you want to call that but the process
but I don't say separate a process of
evolution does not negate the
specialness of me as a conscious human
being I think is the difference being
cut but I put that more on consciousness
than I do on body hair
well it's cut so that's complicated
that's a complicated conversation but
what what I will say is that we tend to
think of ourselves as we're not animals
right even though all evidence points to
the fact that we are we want to say
we're not animals and we're obviously
better than the animals we're obviously
smarter than the animals right and we're
obviously smarter than that chimpanzee
and have no reason to believe that he's
a cousin this I'm just taught you know
and so
you're like well I'm gonna I'm gonna
make myself a less animal-like or maybe
is it so it but so in that sense it's
just like even if that's I and that
could even be subconscious like if
you're if you're picking up a rock sharp
rock and shaving your face or I don't
know was it a knife shaving your face
for the first time you don't even know
why you're doing it it's just like it's
it could just be a foot it could be a
form of self-expression that deeply
rooted was to is to enhance your
separateness and specialness
that's III definitely so even if it's
subconscious I could see it going back
I'm taking I'm taking all this back now
though big what are you thinking I don't
think that the guy was thinking it
because people don't do that people
don't might assume out and think about
them compared to they animals right
themselves in the context of their local
community so now you're talking about
women I think some I I think it's still
on the table if it happens at a
subconscious level yeah I don't think
anybody's saying I'm not a ape alright
look at my face I should I shaved it you
know it's something that you just feel
you want to feel different special but
it might be rooted in something to
separate yourself enhance your no doubt
the first dude who shaved was
interpreted as doing something very
feminine that's where that's what I
think we're actually talking about you
got now you could also say well you know
some people have less facial hair than
others maybe maybe before the first guy
with a beard shaved there was just a guy
without a beard naturally so there's two
two possible scenario with multiple
scenarios but one scenario is you got a
guy who just has less facial hair like
you know my father-in-law for instance
he cannot grow a beard you can't even
close to being a very very slight
mustache and a very very slight goatee
but Broughton like for patchy areas note
no patches he does have anything on the
cheeks if he doesn't shave so you got a
guy like that and if let's say that that
guy who has less
facial hair is for some reason powerful
maybe he's got all the women maybe he
spreading his seed around and so now you
want to compete with that guy you're
like well I've got a big beard maybe the
difference is I got this beard and so
then you shave it off that's one
possible scenario because the other
scenario is all the men had beards now
first of all we don't I mean again we're
just completely talking out of our butts
we don't know why this happened but for
some reason the women lost their facial
hair before men there was a point in
which we all had facial hair but so but
then assuming that the women lost it
before men and then all men had beards
then some dude made a decision to become
more like a woman and that's and maybe
that was his motivation or maybe it was
an accident
did fire come before shaving because
shaving involves like very specific
tools right so which came first fire or
tools sharp enough to shave I'm going
with fire but if you're saying that
somebody got that beard burned off and
then it was like maybe you got like a
blood you know when you're like grilling
and you can you singe some it smells bad
but then you're like Oh grills
definitely came before knives I do know
that yeah say you're okay but you burn
your dude burns his beard off and then
what he made a leader he may think he's
a he's a fashion-forward kind of guy in
the community I don't know I mean again
it could have been as simple as one
powerful woman preferred the guy with
without the beard the guy with a
half-burned beard but who was like I got
to make this thing symmetrical I'm gonna
see if I can get the rest of this off or
maybe there was somebody who had to get
in into something like slip into
something and they needed to do
slightest Luther sauce first
maybe there was a functional reason like
some guy needed to like maybe oh you
know maybe it's there's a guy that was a
designated like guy that like stuck his
face into a beehive or something like of
course that guy wouldn't need a beard
there's got to be a functional reason
why you wouldn't need a beard you know I
think you're good at coming up with
things you don't actually believe hey
good job I'm just wondering if there's a
like when you talk about people who like
genetically they just they don't grow
full beards I think at first they would
grow less beards and it would become
patchy it wouldn't just be all of a
sudden
yeah its gradual it was yeah so at some
point when it's gradual it becomes
patchy to the point where it becomes
more embarrassing than desirable
suddenly like I'm taking the drastic
making this drastic measure of like I'm
shaving the patches off I'd rather have
nothing then have a half half beard all
my boys are grunting and making fun of
me I hear their grunts right now those
are divisive grunts you know so I'm just
gonna take it all the way and then
something something something cool
happened in that person maybe they also
they were cool for other reasons so it
became you know culturally it just
became so because it's because it's
completely because obviously the the
ability and desire to shave is not
that's not in your DNA that's not
something that's passed down your DNA
that's that's cultural right yeah so
it's not like oh the guy who shaved had
more kids and so his kids shaved too i
mean that's not how it works yeah it's
all about it'll treat the culture it's
all yeah it's all about fashion I mean
sexuality I 10 - in power but here's a I
think your thing about power is pretty
like it being associated with a powerful
person or a powerful person making a
choice to influence culture yeah but I
think we maybe we're thinking about you
know you're talking about divisive
grunts which I think we're thinking
about it
it's - - preeya - prehistoric this is
much more easily we're talking like the
Romans were the first people to shave or
something I mean the Roman Empire was
you know several hundred years BC
definitely right before before when it
got started so I'm saying the historical
you know historical humanity like
recorded history yeah it's like post
Stone Age not prehistoric but
historic that my guess is that the first
person who shaved was in historic times
which makes me think that we could have
just Wikipedia this I think at some
point we're gonna have to open the
Internet in this I think we have to do
that in this podcast we can't sit here
and blow smoke for you know tens and
tens of minutes like the history of
Shaving and then just leave it I think
we've got you know we can't leave this
open-ended people are already cracking
up in the internet or they're frustrated
if we're not gonna give a definitive
answer at the end of this I think we
need to find that answer by that by the
end of this conversation there's an
interesting this is interesting we need
to agree before we crack open the
Internet okay I think you and I have to
be like this is what we believe it is
but an interesting thing that you have
broached here and that is the purpose of
conversation this is something I've been
thinking about a lot I've actually been
thinking about this in the context of so
if you're expanding the conversation do
you agree that we are going to I'm
coming back to they're gonna find the
Internet's answer and I will come back
to who's the first person who ever shave
so hang on but yeah go with this this is
if the rabbit-hole can go anywhere I'm
back today I'm still in the hole I'm not
leaving we're still in the hole in
talking about so you know one of the
things we were doing for the tour of
mythicality for the show is we're
bringing different parts of the book to
life that's sort of the backbone on the
show and you know that there's a there
is a chapter written from the future in
the book mm-hmm we literally traffic had
ourselves yeah from the Year 2075 write
an entire chapter of the book of
mythicality it's fascinating we can't
tell you how it was done but it's
absolutely fast it wasn't legal no broke
many different international and it
wasn't legal then but it it's not like
law now it's it's legal now because
there's no law now yet but we're
bringing that potentially that section
of the book to life and one of the
things I talked about one of the things
we talked about the chapter that I was
kind of trying to find a way to for us
to talk
about it in a show today is the idea of
time passing and information processing
even as it relates to entertainment so
that makes me what I'm saying with good
mythical morning you sit down and you
enjoy good mythical morning or air
biscuit or any form of entertainment it
doesn't have to just be something that
we make for an amount of time you set
aside time and of course if you're
listening to a podcast or an audible
book or something like that you might up
the time 1.25 1.5 whatever how fast you
want to move it but there's a limit to
how quickly your brain can process
information and if you were a computer
if you were a perfectly functioning
computer you don't have to take time to
tell a computer a story you can take a
file that has a story on it and put it
into a computer and the computer
immediately processes and is familiar
familiar with it in all the ways that it
needs to be familiar with so in other
words it has it it either has it or it
doesn't have we're recording this
podcast right now and it's it's making a
file that the computer is immediately
the computer doesn't see it as something
that has a beginning and ending it to
seize it as digital information and get
access at any time it has it or does it
doesn't experience it right and over the
course of time and what's happening with
artificial intelligence is really
interesting because you know we are
headed lightning-fast to some sort of
intelligence that will immediately as
soon as there is something that can be
as intelligent as a human emotionally it
will be infinitely more intelligent
already from you know a mathematical
standpoint because your your phone is
way smarter than us mathematically
already so sure right
so assuming there's going to be and then
there's probably going to be a time in
which we're able to figure out how to
have an interface between our brains and
a computer and we're gonna in the same
way that right now our lives are sort of
supported and propped up by these memory
devices like the reason that I knew you
were going to the dentist and you knew
you were going to the dentist wasn't
because you remembered but because it
was on your phone for all intents and
purposes but if you expand upon knew it
it had it if you expand that out
you say well this phone is now attached
to my head yeah it's inside my skull
now entertainment becomes something that
you can simply download so so you become
like a character in a role-playing video
game that it's can walk into like a shop
and buy an experience the ability to
wield a sword and it might be like and
it's not just abilities abilities is
real that's a really interesting
conversation but I'm specifically
talking about experiences so it might be
like I want to know what it's like to
climb Mount Everest I want to know what
it's like to have Kobe beef I want to
know what it's like to have so yeah so
in that case you would be implanted with
the data of a memory so then you would
be implanted with have you ever climbed
Mount Everest and you'd be like yes it
was amazing and you could you could talk
about it you know extensively as well as
even better than if you actually
experienced it and then remembered it
because the faults associated with with
memory right so it raises the question
about the book we talked about how the
future of good mythical morning is that
it will not be enjoyed as a linear
experience over time it will be enjoyed
as data that is simply injected into
your brain that's the future of good
mythical morning that's the future of
entertainment sounds depressing now
isn't it but as it relates to this
conversation this is really interesting
because you're saying here we are two
guys who don't really know what they're
talking about but like to talk yeah and
can talk about the first guy that ever
shaved and you're talking about saying
well listen we could just go to the
internet and get the definitive answer
maybe we can't maybe we can't we don't
know they probably don't know but we get
could get the best answers from the best
people but then we wouldn't have had
this conversation so the question is is
there is being implanted with the
experience the same as the experience if
you perceive it in exactly the same way
in one second after you get back home
from Everest you feel exactly the same
way as the guy who didn't go and simply
had an implant
his brain so you both feel and perceive
exactly the same thing about your trip
to Everest absolutely not that's not the
same thing it's not the same thing but
you would believe you would believe
you've done it except you knew that
technology existed that you that it's
possible that you didn't climb Mount
Everest you just believed it with your
whole heart and mind it can get you can
control that part of the technology
could say part of the flag this one as
this may I will think that I did this
one like this is not one that will be
implanted in my brain that I know
definitively that I didn't do I want you
to convince me that I did this so for
the rest of your life do you know how
they would do that they would do it by
tapping into the party they would
subvert that part of your brain the
neurons that are associated with
pathological lying and I'm not
comfortable with that like the people
who can lie they can they lie things
they believe I don't want to alter my
brain in that way though and I think
that's how science would do oh well you
don't have a way to have a way to do it
man it's lying to yourself yeah so and
then what is your reality because you
could be like I mean the the the most
immediate application for this
technology is trauma is people who've
been affected by horrible experiences
people have been abused and been through
horrible experiences who've developed
some sort of Stockholm Syndrome or
whatever well I think that's a noble
twisting of neurons right and so in
those cases you could say we don't want
to add experiences but we want to
subtract experiences but once you figure
out how to do that then you're like well
why are we going to add experiences in
my but I don't wanna get into that it's
a whole different conversation but I
could think my thing is is that I do
value the conversation that we're having
yeah because I think I think if your
question getting back to this is would
you just like to know the answer and is
it what's more valuable knowing the
answer who was the first guy who ever
shaved and maybe why or all the details
that the internet would offer or would
you rather
have the experience of listening to two
idiots
trying to seem really smart but
potentially being totally off-base for
an hour well we are comedians we are let
us not forget that and I hope that's
very valuable but instinctively I felt
like it wasn't valuable enough so I was
like we got to put this thing on the end
so I kind of I I presented the conundrum
here which it's a hard question to
answer you're too short circuit he had
to choose one or the other but you know
doesn't have both would you were gonna
give both we're gonna find out the
answer here in just a few minutes
because it because that but if we didn't
huh
it would this will be a very frustrating
podcast and that was my concern and why
we said we need to come up with an
answer is that does that give us an
answer to your larger question of would
you rather know something and believe
you experienced it or never know it if
it was a lie
would you rather would you rather
download the experience of Everest but
never actually go or either go or don't
go would you would you be would you stay
old school would you take the pill the
climbing Everest pill well first of all
there are people who think differently
about you there's people who are very
scared of Technology and you know
putting anything into their body you
know there was that company that
everybody lot I think they were in
Sweden maybe was America maybe this has
happened in Europe but there was at one
company where they lined up and they
gave people the little chip in between
their thumb and their index finger oh
yeah and it was you know according to
the company and about 50 per it was
optional and they paid for it but it was
like 50% of the employee sign up for and
it was basically their security
clearance to get into the building was
built into their their thumb okay so
basically just a key something as simple
as a but that's a bit that's a big
choice for just the convenience of not
having to lose your keys you know I
would get an implant just to get into my
work without my badge but obviously this
is just step one of many right because
at some point we're gonna be like well
why can't we also
my social security number and my
personal information of my medical
records on on me at all times
so there are people for good reason let
me just be one of the first people to
say there's very good reason to be very
cautious about that kind of thing you
know less people from particular
backgrounds and particularly
understandings are like oh this is the
this is the mark of the beast that is
foretold in the book of Revelation and
that's what these people are getting
themselves into this is a real bad thing
and even people who don't think that and
just think just believe that you should
have some sort of privacy and the
government shouldn't know all this stuff
there's there's good reasons to be
scared of the technology I on the other
hand I'm like I feel like this is all
inevitable and we're gonna have to just
move forward with the technological
advances and be very cautious as we
embrace them but realize that ultimately
there is a you can't hold back this
flood that's going to happen with us
becoming one with machines I don't think
you can actually hold it back and while
you were talking I concluded I will take
the climbing Everest pill right which is
because yeah and and then at first I'll
say with the flag on it on the file that
I know that I really didn't do it so
yeah you can experience it but then yeah
I don't like the idea of like lying to
myself yeah I'm not comfortable with
believing like like a pathological liar
or worse because at that point you are
like lying to myself I don't think
that's healthy but I think I might be
comfortable with like I'm sitting in a
chair and I'm like you know what I took
that pill two years ago I'm gonna I'm
gonna relive climbing Everest right now
in my own mind like a prisoner would do
in like a Cell who like thinks about
when he used to walk on the outside and
then you can delete it - maybe it's a
free trial maybe there's like a seven
day free trial for the Everest thing and
then you just do it for seven days and
then you forget to stone and out just
thinking about man it's like once I got
up there it was tough I had to really
alter my breathing because I ran out of
the oxygen because I think what you're
talking about is if you can't separate
yourself whatever it is that yourself is
from the memory that's been in place
then who are you right because then at
that point you can just give me a
completely new identity
and I could be a different self which is
the which is the whole crazy thing that
you know you talk about like travelling
across the universe well we're always
going to be able to send information
much faster than physical matter right
we're always gonna be able to send
information faster than matter because
matter has got to get up to you know
there's all kind of limitations with
propelling matter across the universe
but information moves pretty fast and
and when that information becomes
yourself then you can save yourself you
can travel to any place so at that point
if we find a way to represent the self
as a collection of digital information
which obviously we're getting into lots
of philosophical questions about is that
all you are let's just say for this
argument it is all you are and you can
be implanted in a cyborg that never gets
old and you can just change yourself out
oh I broke my arm I'll just put a new
arm on and so now you are this wealth
yeah you show up and I want to show up
in Sweden you show yourself to a
different cyborg or Mars or anyplace
else and ultimately if there are aliens
and statistically speaking there
probably are it'd be very difficult to
believe that there aren't beardless I do
anyway they're definitely beardless I
don't think that they've come to visit
us yet but when they do come and visit
us if they come and visit us it will be
in that fashion it will be it won't be
the internet it won't be beardless being
showing up on spaceships it will be
suddenly you'll look down and there will
there will be matter assembling itself
next to you into a being that has found
a way to shoot information across the
universe and take it take the matter
from your planet and assemble itself
into a coherent being that's how they're
gonna come I don't think that will
happen and I think I think they'll have
to be a conduit so there'll be shells
they'll be avatar shells like physical
shell people well that's like what
that's the movie where they shot they've
basically planted themselves they have
to have containers deeply and never have
bodies if you can get you can't you
can't send
there's a greedy mail it through the
internet but what's that what's that
matter for me if you can get destroyed
if what I'm saying is that if you are
technologically sophisticated enough to
send matter across the universe ADA to
not man no matter because that because
you're talking about physical things
being planted yeah yeah so if you're a
shell they shell exactly if you're
technologically sophisticated enough to
sin matter whether that shells or ships
or seeds across the universe to another
planet you already have gotten to a
place where you're technologically
sophisticated enough to send data that
can have information that then assembles
the matter that you have access to on
the plane oh you're saying that the data
bowls pulls resources from the soil it
doesn't create orc or it like attaches
to the side of a skyscraper and then
like pulls bricks off the side okay yeah
I believe in the data yeah the data
point is that and no one's done I saw
what you were saying matter from nothing
I don't know I don't read a lot of
science fiction but you know their story
I think that no but I don't somebody
needs to make a movie about this if I
had somebody we will Oh somebody's got
to make a movie about that's how the
aliens get here first you sci-fi fans
who've read a lot more than I have you
got to tell me that somebody's thought
of this that that's how the aliens come
they come as information that assembles
itself using the atoms in our in our
earth but we're not going to answer that
here I don't because I got to get back
to the first guy who shaved but before
we do right would you would you take
them climbing Mount Everest memory pill
yes without a flag without a flag
definitely
I'm the guy who's first in line to
embrace all the weird stuff would do you
think I would think I would take it with
a flag because I don't think it again
I've already told you why no but here's
know what I don't want to fool myself as
two different guys though if you have
the flag and I don't have the flag when
we sit down and talk about every shoe it
I didn't really do it but I'm like but I
did really do it like I just I got a
better story because I really did it you
know you forgot you had the memory and
planning without the flag I had the flag
and now we're just in an argument about
who's got the flag I'm like no I don't
have the flag constantly you're like you
can't get the flag implanted because
that's part of the package I'm like
don't ruin it for
me I loved Everest right I lost this
finger oh it's back right and then see
how that ruins our friendship yeah you
see what you've done to us I think what
this means is that friends have to do
things together exactly the same way
like we both have to go take the flag or
don't take the flag with or without the
flag we got to make a decision or else
you just lose I really think you'll be a
you will even with the flag
I honestly think you will be a better
person I think it can make you a better
person
yeah to experience I mean think if you
climb Mount Everest doesn't that make
you a better person it impacts your life
yeah it just makes you better period if
I met if I saw you guy that went on top
of me he's better than me it's like
watching a movie you can watch movies
that make you bet a better as a person
and you can watch movies that I guess
make you worse as a person oh yeah
anything Tarantino does what the other
day I was sitting here Nino was in the
office we're in our office no not ours
but where where where I'm supervising
the post on buddy system you're kidding
he was yeah the editor said I went to
the bathroom
no no you're kidding and he said QT was
in a building which he said I did he
comes back and he's like I was just in
the bathroom with Quentin Tarantino
Quinn Tarantino does post at the same
facility we do yes we go yeah we go he
no I I picture him doing it ain't a
theater at his house in the hills he
came to this place and he was at a
urinal and he said it was really weird
cuz he was he had both hands above his
head against the wall of course I said
and he was like he was leaning into the
urinal that'll do it for now on no bend
in the elbows hands outstretched
splattered against you know why he does
plate against the wall so we'll talk
about it like I don't yeah Scott said I
I was like that's Quentin Tarantino I
can't I can't bring myself to say
anything to him because of his posture
at this urine you don't talk to Quentin
Tarantino when he's pissing we all know
you don't talk to him anyway definitely
middle of that and he said and plus he
looked really disheveled what when does
he not he's um he's supervising
the extended cut of Django Unchained
which is going to be released on Netflix
what who would have thought that theirs
isn't the extended incident the
directors cut what Quentin Tarantino
puts out period like quitting Tarantino
puts out whatever you want not in the
days of Netflix when you get that little
legs I scratch yeah but now he has a he
has an even a directed director cut he's
thinking about all that money he's
making is he just pees all all of the
liquids out he's gotta so an even longer
Django Unchained is coming away that's
the hot that's the hot news that I got
for you
I would I you can't put the flag on well
but by the way that was that was a
memory that was implanted what if this
whole thing is a pill that we well let's
not even get into the fact that it's all
simulation certainty that we are living
in a simulation already I haven't seen
him I'll let you know if I see him so
you take it with the you take it with
the flag or you take it without the flag
yes that's your site I gotta have the
flag as if I'm gonna do it as well yeah
so it's like watching a movie but it's
it's a movie that's my memory and it has
to feel different because it that it's a
memory trip I'm taking a memory trip
he's not a Merle Haggard lyric I think
his memory trips and fight the pain yeah
cuz he Tama its he's a prisoner of war
yeah that's all you got when you're when
you got when you're in prison are you
memory trips and think about I mean
there's no gas Elvis we could sell this
technology to prisoners well there's
absolutely cigarette there's absolutely
no doubt that when this is figured out
if we don't annihilate ourselves before
we get to this point technologically
which is I'd say it's more likely that
if we annihilate ourselves as a species
before we get technologically or
environmentally or yeah yeah we got all
kinds like 15 different ways that we
could everything could be blown up in
the next hundred shoes but let's just
say we get lucky and we make it through
against all odds well there's no doubt
that this technology is going to happen
and you know I was listening to
something on a podcast the other day and
they were talking about
you know if you were to bring somebody
before the technological revolution to
the current day they would not be able
to process anything that they were
seeing could even begin to process it
and to think about because of the
principle of accelerated change that
things continue to change more quickly
as they change there's no doubt that
there's gonna be a time that if we were
to travel to the Year 2075 over let's
just say 30
you know 2175 whatever we would
encounter something that we couldn't
even process and so we're processing
this stuff right now we're talking about
implanting memories and trips to Everest
and that kind of thing but to think
about the technological advances will be
things that we can't even couldn't
process or have conversations about
right now that will be more advanced
than the things that we're talking about
because surely the things we're talking
about are gonna come to pass because
they they're just precursors to the
crazy things that will come after yeah
so this is all you may think we're just
nuts right this stuff is gonna happen
guys we're gonna be faced with these
these questions you're gonna be able to
look at a library and hit a button and
get all the get all the information and
it won't be an actual library that those
want exists but by library event but
they'll be like a hipster retro what's
it called skin yeah they'll be like a
hipster library skin you can put on it
and it will be what you choose it from
it will be most likely based on how much
money you have that will be how you get
the information you know unless somebody
decides that's fine
the older the ultra-rich can become self
deluged and then it'll be up to us to
finally take control oh okay you got to
be part of the revolution huh yeah
instead of the bourgeoisie yeah I think
I want to be a part of the booze Rosie
so just sitting up there thinking I'm on
top of Everest with a mai tai in my hand
who was the first guy that'll be a
frozen might I uh well it's alcoholic
drink it won't freeze that's the beauty
of what you said huh oh no the rat
where's the rabbit hole going so the
first guy who ever shaved you guys have
laptops Kim
borrow one and have you already have you
been looking this up or have you been
doing your own internet Cody was ready
he's got Google up so let's first of all
I'm Jacob you go the first guy back up
Google this stuff seeping fire save Cody
I'm having trouble first guy we ever
shaved has a parental warning you know
what you don't want to see that you
don't want to see anything shaved give
us the password we're gonna we're gonna
ruin your internet history here
alright so literally just type in who is
no typing the question I don't want to
see if we say the first guy I've ever
shaved and just see if our song comes up
oh the history of shaving modern gent
calm and then we got the Guardian when
and why did men start shaving off their
beards hmm
let's just go with the history of
shaving now this is not like a this does
not look like a pro site this is like a
white site with this black text on it
and like a very boring sidebar menu and
where one of the items is asked the
barber Egyptian shaved their beards and
heads which was a custom adopted by
grieves in Roman 330 BC shaving predates
history but it was early Egyptian men
and women who really is to have a
shaving and hair removal as a regular
part of daily grooming hold on hold on I
said we were gonna agree before we
started looking into this and then we
got this laptop and we didn't agree we
got so over frickin zealous we didn't
land no neither one of us know what was
wrong no what I said was I said it was
after history so that's different than
this we've already been proven wrong but
we change on predates history I want to
get it on after history that's what I
wanted us to agree because I was about
to talk about the Egyptian well let me
implant that in your brain right as I
was saying I believe it it started with
the Egyptians that's what it's gonna be
like in the future man if if you're
having a if your two guys are having an
argument whoever gets to the implant
faster is the one who wins the argument
you know it's just like I want this guy
to agree with me and then you say his
little code and he agrees with you so
you
wrong because in the age of Google in
your pocket or in your glasses it would
eradicate all arguments that's the sad
that's the sad thing about humanity I
want to talk that's another rabbit hole
because I have a whole whole like theory
about using artificial intelligence and
letting them rule us I actually have a
theory about why that would ultimately
be better but you know people gonna hate
me because I'm saying why can't
arguments the reason why Google doesn't
solve arguments because arguments aren't
about being right or wrong they're about
other things but you can pretty you can
most all in the program artificial
intelligence to only be concerned with
truth and then let them lead but that's
a real crappy website men scrape their
hair away in early times in early times
man with crude items such as stone Flint
clam shells and other sharpen materials
he later experimented with bronze copper
and iron razors how do they know this
they don't keep reading why though why
when and how people started shaving read
dad okay being so clean all the time was
associated with fanatical behavior by
outsiders the ancient Romans thought
that a lack of major body hair was some
kind of terrible deformity but not in
Egypt where priests believed that body
hair was shameful and unclean okay
religious belief and cleanliness that
makes sense wild animals and barbarians
had hair that's where I said yeah bought
animals not the sophisticated and
advanced Egyptian civilization being
hairless was achieved by shaving using
debility creams and rubbing ones hair
off with a pumice stone it sounds gosh
click on the Guardian article you never
go resorting to the Guardian for for
truth I don't know if that's a good idea
I don't know what about a guardian oh
okay
an analysis a fashion picture shows that
beardless ness began among young men and
1890s okay give me a frickin break you
going back to 1890s I did went on
ancestry.com the other night and took my
whole family back to the 1700s is
this are you reading comments or an
article that was Dave Noll from
Claremont California Dave your whole
comment is null because you did not read
Ian's in the 1890 you're not reading an
article you're reading a form that's
titled the body beautiful here's
somebody from here's Nora from Chapel
Hill
the ancient Romans also shave their
beards well I don't know much about
fashion these people are just these all
these people are worse than us like
click out of this
The Guardian just gets a bunch of
numbskulls to come in and just say what
they think that's that's what this whole
podcast is is two numbskulls saying what
they think we need definitive
information shaving Wikipedia that's
what I said about an hour ago shaving is
the removal of hay oh now we're onto it
now we get to the good stuff I mean is
the removal of hair shine like shaving
in real history before the advent of
razors here was where I can read it
silently while you read it out loud
before the advent of razors hair was
sometimes removed using two shells to
pull the hair out ooh we're using water
and a sharp tool around 3,000 BC when
copper tools were developed copper
razors were invented okay so they
probably found copper razors the idea of
an aesthetic approach to personal
hygiene may have begun at this time
though Egyptian priests may have
practiced something similar to this
earlier yeah because a static approach
to personal hygiene that's two things
that's fashion aesthetic and personal
hygiene which is yes something weird you
know Alexander the Great strongly
promoted shaving during his reign in the
4th century BC because he believed it
looked high Diehr
in some Native American tribes at the
time of contact with British colonists
it was customary for men and women to
remove all bodily hair using these
methods oh okay all right
when was that what's the earliest that
we're hearing right now 3,000 beasts No
3,000 BC I think upper tools
yeah 3,000 BC but I think the point is
is if there was a custom that the
colonists ran into with the Native
Americans of a Native Americans its
controversial how long they've been here
but maybe as much as 40,000 years
probably more like 20,000 years they've
been in North America so you have to
assume that that custom originated way
before we just showed up
it's probably one of those things this
thing happening simultaneously in
cultures because it can be done it will
be done
yeah right yep because you can do
something to your body to express
yourself and maybe it's associated with
a belief of Hygiene or uh you know
spirituality I think the bottom line is
it happened because it could happen
right that's as simple as that like
you've got something on you that can be
taken off well okay let's try that yeah
it's no enough people live people things
happen it's really no different than
saying why do why do people configure
their hair in different styles yeah I
mean I we could ask that question about
ourselves right I still don't have an
answer yeah we do we we got a whole
chapter in the book about it we wrote
about it in the book yeah well that
wasn't the like the earth-shattering
groundbreaking answer that we were
hoping for it's pretty it's just pretty
simple it's like if it can be altered on
the human body it's as soon as you can
think about it it's gonna happen would
you like a more fantastical explanation
I think we've given those but the one
the one with the guy grilling is my is
is what I'm going I'll give my
alternative explanation that is that an
ancient alien species but that was a
technologically sophisticated enough to
transmit data that had the ability to
control matter and also it had evolved
to the point that all of their hair was
gone which is clearly the path that were
on no no it was much simpler than that
they were just practical jokers Oh
and they sent themselves to earth
because they they're so technologically
advanced they just do things for kicks
now they sent one of their dudes to
assemble himself as some weird dirt man
you know hundreds of thousands of years
ago and he was and he came out and he
like made this motion like shave but he
was clean-shaven yeah well I don't know
his methods I know that how I got there
he didn't have a beard he did something
to encourage the first person to shave
and that's why people shave in my
alternate theory and you know why I did
it
because it's because someone write for
kicks because someone in that alien race
this just needs to do stuff for kicks
had to go do a new thing for kicks in
order to create the data that could then
be in
in taneous Lee passed along to everyone
else of his or her race so that they
could say you never guess what I did
yesterday and they were let let me
experience it I traveled to a planet I
got off to I assembled myself and I made
like a shaving motion yeah it was
hilarious I've been shaving for
thousands of years there now and then
night now whenever we go back I bet you
those fools will be shaving yeah right
yeah I did that no you didn't you you
didn't put the flag on that was the
expansion pack and that's what's
happening oh yeah what comes back I'm
gonna stay in this rabbit hole forever
Wow oh yeah we're never gonna get out of
it that was just one question
we'll do it if you like this thanks
Frank we'll do this again I enjoy going
down the rabbit hole and if he hated it
let us know as well something you
probably did but we still love you we'll
talk at you next week this
[Music]